choice to get an abortion is an
infringement on women's rights and that
it's going to keep kind of coming after
women's rights and that kind of thing so
it kind of brings in the feminist
movement with are they going to go after
wins votes are they going to go after
women being able to do this and do that
so what do you think about that in terms
of the women's rights perspective what
about the child's rights it's like I
think the child's rights at conception
there's a unique DNA sequence that's
different from the mother and the
fathers right that DNA sequence has the
eye color hair color personality traits
and in China you see you see something
where they're aborting women that's
because of the one child policy so what
about those women so and that's that's
the problem with abortion is it becomes
a slippery slope to Eugenics where a lot
of the arguments I hear people make are
something along the lines of poor people
should shouldn't live and shouldn't be
alive when everyone on Earth is richer
than most people were in all of human
history you know by that logic no one
should be